we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P there is a very
wealthy caller who doesn't like what I
do and is going to try to get me removed
from YouTube listen to this
hey punk ass kid hey I'm gonna call
YouTube and tell them I'm gonna back out
my support for them if they don't take
down every post on YouTube that you've
made whoa so don't be surprised Monday
if there ain't none of yours left on
YouTube whoa I'm a very wealthy man I
pay a lot of money to YouTube you little
broke pieces waste of sperm wow wow well
we are going to look into that very very
strongly and uh I do hope and pray that
by the time you hear that voicemail all
of our videos haven't been removed from
YouTube alright so we'll look into that
very strongly we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today we are now learning
about the judge who is going to handle
Donald Trump's arraignment tomorrow the
judge is considered no-nonsense
we are going to talk about that number
two
the Twitter blue check marks for
verified individuals rather than people
who just are signing up for Twitter blue
what is happening there is Major drama
involving the New York Times
it's crazy what is going on with Twitter
uh verification and it's the continued
decline of Twitter which we will discuss
and lastly Brittany Greiner is calling
for the release of an American reporter
detained in Russia much like she
previously was it is all escalating it
is all building and we are talking about
all of it on the bonus show oh the bonus
show
now not only with an anti-endorsement
from Alex Jones but with an
anti-endorsement from Candace Owens
David Pacman does not have a soul he
doesn't have a soul okay if that
anti-endorsement makes you curious about
the bonus show then by all means sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indicted but you have to spell it
correctly Trump spelled it indicated
when he posted about being indicted that
won't work as a coupon code but the
correctly spelled indicted will save you
big bucks at joinpakman.com I will see
you on the bonus show and then on
tomorrow's show then on the Trump
arraignment live stream and then on the
Trump press conference live stream much
going on in the next 36 hours